we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this is
funny it's actually kind of good news
we've not heard from previously drunk
furious trump is jimmy from philly for a
while but he is requesting a name change
take a listen
hey every Jimmy from Philly yeah from
Maryland since I've stopped drinking I
demand you referred to me as the furious
psycho not trumps my Twitter it's a
longer the drunk Trump supporter because
I'm not drinking anymore but the psycho
not would be the appropriate term
okay so Jimmy I don't know I I'm glad
that you're not drinking anymore because
the drinking was becoming a problem
Jimmy was having on some nights that he
would call into the live streams I don't
remember if it was four or six of like a
very high alcohol percentage IPA and
India Pale Ale for the uninitiated which
by the way who likes super hoppy beers
give me a break but that's a story for a
different day and I think they were like
eleven percent so he was having like
four to six which I believe is like
eight to twelve normal beers if a normal
beer is like five percent I think some
of those like you know water beers like
Bud Light or maybe even like two or
three percent this guy was putting down
a lot of alcohol so I'm glad that you're
not drinking I think psychonaut might be
a reference to the fact that Jimmy now
does LSD II I don't know if that's a
code word for someone who does LSD but
in any case Jimmy seems more lucid when
he calls in and for that I think we can
all be grateful we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today
Democratic congressman when Katie Hill
is resigning because of allegations of
improper relationships with staffers we
will talk about that the police officer
who was told to tone down his gayness
their word not mine has been awarded
nineteen million dollars in a
discrimination lawsuit and a big gap a
chasm or chasm depending on something
has opened up on the issue of
reparations where seventy-five percent
of African Americans support reparations
for slavery whereas only fifteen percent
of white Americans do according to a new
poll and we are going to dig in to a lot
of what is going on with that issue on
today's bonus show please get today's
bonus show the bonus show is for members
and patrons you can get instant access
at david pakman.com slash membership or
by becoming a patron at the $5 a month
or greater level at patreon.com slash
david pakman show